ما زالت الاعمال العسكريه مستمره في جنوبي
وشرق اوكرانيا وما زالت مقاطعه دانيس تشهد
اعنف المعارك على الاطلاق تزامنا مع وصوله
امدادات عسكريه من روسيا لا سيما بعد
اعلان موسكو عن التعبئه الجزئيه اواخر
العامل الماضي فشمال المقاطعه يشهدوا
تقدما للقوات الروسيه على الاراضي التي
سيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني سابقا وقواته
فاجنر بسطت نفودها على مزيد من الاراضي
والبلدات حول مدينه باخمط بعد ان اكملت
السيطره على جوانبها الثلاثه وتقطع
الامدادات عن المقاتلين الاوكرانيين
المحاصرين داخل المدينه من الطرق السريعه
المؤديه من الناحيه الغربيه الى مدينتي
شسوفيا
وتحاول قوته اختراقه مدينه اخبط من
الناحيه الجنوبيه حيث تنطلق العمليات
العسكريه من مدينه كليشكا وصولا الى مدينه
ايفانكا وتتقدم القوات الروسيه من شمال
باخمود نحو مدينه سيفرز التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني بعد سيطرهم على مدينتي
وسوليدار ومزيد من البلدات لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاخضر